look at this year Revenue in 2020
Veritas brought in 22 million thirty
four thousand dollars I can only imagine
with this Pfizer video here's what I
think it's the money and I'll tell you
why this some people are like I think
Pfizer came in and did something I'm not
so sure about that that would be bad PR
wise like you don't want to pour fuel on
a fire of a story by it
there's a story of these activists who
were protesting outside of McDonald's
saying McDonald's is bad McDonald's sued
them one and then their stock tanked
because the news reporting was that
massive Corporation attacks to private
individuals Pfizer's got to be like that
everyone's cheering these guys on if we
go after them it's going to hurt us
Let's ignore it here's what I think
2020 take a look at these numbers in
2019 project Veritas brings in 12
million 151 496 one year later they
nearly double their revenue to 22
million
how much money do you think is going to
come in now that they had the biggest
stories this biggest story ever in the
history of veritas I could only imagine
they're going to hit 40 50 million okay
maybe I'm maybe I'm I'm way off with the
40 was my first thought 40 right now
imagine you're on the board and you're
like
guys look how much money we have I've I
could never have and then James says we
are not using the money for what you
want we are going to use the money the
way I see it and we're going to do the
mission and I don't think the board
members necessarily are thinking I'm
gonna stuff my pockets but they're
saying something like let's use the
funds to build a new building and we can
start doing this and that and we can put
a gym there and then James is like we're
gonna do this we're going to do this
we're going to expose this you gotta get
rid of this is what I said when we first
got war that he was suspended if you
want access to the cash you've got to
get rid of the ideological founder who's
standing in the way of that big pile of
money now for them to come out with a
new excuse that you as misappropriating
funds it's it's projecting right it's
what we typically see from these
leftists they accuse others well they've
got board members posting their pronouns
in their Twitter bios and accusing
someone else of malfeasance and how do
board members get on board they donate
to the organization right so if you had
a year like this and again like I used
to work in fundraising
the the top amount of money comes from a
very narrow number of donors typically
right so I think yes they have really
great Grassroots support but there are
probably a couple new donors who saw the
work they have done and said I am
willing to really either scale up what
I'm giving or I'm willing to give a huge
donation for the first time now that's a
threat to all the other board members
right they are in potentially going to
lose their position if they are now
competing with these other high dollar
donors I think that this is a sketchy
thing to do especially when your
organization is uh doing so well has
this big story out unless you personally
feel threatened it seems like James is
uh intimating it's it's Pfizer he he
said the only thing that has changed is
that we broke the biggest story in our
organization's history during the last
week of January in 2023 with 50 plus
million views our video became a global
phenomenon he then goes on to add more
context and says that is the only thing
that has changed then suddenly an
unusual emergency happened just a few
days after the story he continued
and then he says on Thursday February
2nd I was informed by an officer of
veritas on the phone while enroute to
the airport that he would resign unless
I stepped down as CEO
can I want to address that the Pfizer
connection I gotta I got a question on
my show over at the blaze today someone
asked me why what would be Pfizer's
incentive to produce a product or any
product that could potentially be
harmful to its customers
when its customers are um you know are
people in in need of healthcare
you and I aren't Pfizer's customers
governments are
go no one within the sound of my voice
paid for a covet vaccine government's
paid for all of those you're not paying
for Pak slovit I know some people who
did pay for it uh they were doing like a
hundred dollar yeah yeah okay but but
okay in general in general yes
governments are being pedantic I know
but governments and that's all right to
be exact governments are the clients
what fight would he put out with that
video didn't put heat on Pfizer
they're indemnified going back to 1986
further in under Reagan further
indemnified by the perp act under uh or
other prep act under under Trump
the the heat's not on them that that
Haze in the barn they've cashed all
those checks
the heat is on the is on governments
people aren't calling Pfizer after they
watch those videos they know that that
nothing happens calling Pfizer God bless
there was a group of New Yorkers over
the weekend that did a rally in front of
Pfizer speaking my love language
chanting Nuremberg too Adam and that's
my love language but that doesn't do any
good the governments are the clients
Israel let Pfizer essentially experiment
on their population for an entire year
that's what our government did that's
what almost every major government in
the world did with Pfizer and moderna
they let their people be the real-time
human trial
in real time and possible and so when
when he puts that video out Pfizer the
the horse doctor alborla at Pfizer he's
not sweating it governments are a horse
doctor yeah that's what he was he was a
horse doctor all right and and so the
veterinarian advisor is not sweating it
they're con the governments are the
governments are still somewhat depending
on what your views of elections are
somewhat still accountable to their
people in ways that the corporation at
Pfizer is not and that's a whole new
layer of heat and it's not just our
government people around the world guys
watch those videos and said hey why is
the German do you guys know what's going
on with excess deaths in Germany right
now they're higher right now than they
have been in the entire time of covid-19
they're higher right now in Germany 40
percent higher than normal that's higher
than they were at the peak of the of the
of the initial wave of covet in 2020.
how do we explain those things his video
opens up that entire Pandora
we'll slow down and go back and address
a lot of this stuff uh what's the name
Albert borla Albert borla and he he was
literally a horse he was literally a
horse doctor so but hold on hold on
you're not being cute you're like no he
actually was treating horses yes
specifically yes so when they tried to
tell you that Ivermectin was horse paced
no it wasn't ivermectin's a Nobel prize
winning drug from 2015. it was
repurposed for animal use because of how
effective it was for humans we do that
with a lot of drugs by the way a lot of
our human antibiotics are repurposed for
animals all right well so he was
actually a horse doctor they're always
guilty guys they're always guilty
they're always guilty of what you accuse
you of so Trump's compromised by a
Russian p-tape it turns out Hunter Biden
is literally filming his compromise
videos with Russian hookers while
they're accusing that of they're always
always guilty of what they accuse you of
that's actually interesting because we
often talk about the Ukraine gate how
they accuse Trump of doing what Biden
actually yes but the p-type thing
actually is a good point too because it
was Hunter yes but no it's worst Pace
but it was actually he's actually a
horse doctor I wanted to point this out
because
um I don't know a lot of people probably
don't like Rick and Morty but you know
the mom and the show Beth is a horse
surgeon and they make fun of her calling
her not a real surgeon and she gets
really offended by it and it's just
funny that this guy is like a horse
doctor he's like not a real doctor like
works on horses but I don't know I just
wanted to bring that up anyway but uh
here's what I think I was gonna have
this question for you a few sentences
ago is that you talk about Nuremberg you
know your book rise of the fourth Reich
and all that
we we fed a lot of Libertarians come on
the show and talk about I don't know
where you end up on the on the economic
scale or whatever
I'm not entirely convinced that um this
is a problem that is completely free or
what could be solved by laissez-faire
capitalism or just straight capitalism I
think I think this is a problem of it I
think what happens is as much as I
prefer you know capitalist system over
say like a socialism don't get me wrong
I do think there's still an issue here
and of course the issue uh let's let me
slow down and walk through this because
I understand government is a problem in
this one here's the problem we face with
solving an issue like this
government mandates things because
they're lazy inept evil or otherwise
some are ideological and think now's our
chance we have you know lockdowns are
good for the climate and things like
that others are panicked and say well my
people are screaming do something they
don't care what I do as long as I do
something then Along Comes a big
pharmaceutical company who you mentioned
correctly the governments are the
customers the government says this is it
I'll take Public Funding we'll we'll buy
products from this this major
pharmaceutical and then it looks like I
did something the major pharmaceutical
says we don't care we're immune and we
have guaranteed government contracts so
it's a perfect storm of government
cronyism government corruption you're
describing fascism of course right and
ultimately what it is is the lucrative
merger of Corporation and state Elites
in the public and private sector the
classic definition what I see culturally
governmentally and and and in the
corporate system
I don't necessarily believe is
definitively mustache twirling villains
who are trying to destroy the planet I
know we've had many conversations about
population reduction about how you know
the New York Times I think I think was
the times wrote that the lockdowns the
planet's healing now and that maybe we
need climate change lockdowns they
literally use the line from Avengers end
game when Captain America says well you
know after half the world was uh
disappeared the animals are back in the
Hudson yeah wow but I I kind of just
feel like it's more like a Jackson
Pollock painting than something as
precise as Rembrandt it is quite
literally the chaos of our cultural
Decay the system itself breaking down in
every different area that we've got
cultural collapse corporate and
governmental collapse that results in
nobody wanting to take responsibility
for the hard decisions and just saying
path of least resistance and leave me
the F alone and so we get all of this
mess I think it's I think it's all of
the above I I think that first of all
the number one issue at play here is the
spiritual and moral decline of the West
and you are watching a level of
spiritual darkness and malevolence I had
uh we we had a private dinner with
Tucker Carlson out in Iowa this summer
when he came out to MC and eventforce
and one of the questions we asked him
was hey what happened to the the bow tie
smiling libertarian who was friends with
Rachel Maddow and MSNBC and CNN and
thought frankly people like us you know
these dreaded uh you know Jesus Freaks
that we were the death knell of the
Republican party and we're going to be
the reason why y'all never won any
elections how did you become our
favorite talk show host what what
happened with you because this isn't the
same guy that was on MSNBC 20 years ago
and he said something I thought that was
very profound and I think really does
sum up the era in which we live he said
you know I I'm a kid I grew up in
Georgetown Tucker said my dad was a GOP
operative everybody I was around were
political uh you know kids of
politicians or political operatives we
trick-or-treated together we hung out
together we went to school together we
did Christmas together I could see why
someone might think Medicare and
Medicaid might be the best way to help a
certain disadvantaged group of people
even if my ideology doesn't agree but I
don't think that causes me suspicion
about your motivations he says what's
happened in this current ERA in America
and really throughout the West is
decisions are being made that no one
truly benefits from like we can disagree
vehemently you know ideologically about
affirmative action but somebody is
affirmatively benefiting from that even
if we think the the overall collateral
damage doesn't justify it you disagree
with that there is someone benefiting
from it no one benefits from kids being
sent off to the island of Dr Moreau from
meatballs surgery no one's benefiting
from that no one's benefiting from the
stuff that we're talking about right now
and he said when I analyze this as a kid
who just grew up in the in the
traditional political process and I and
I see people and I go to my liberal
friends and I'm asking why are you guys
doing stuff like this and they suddenly
don't have answers but they're just
going to do them anyway he goes That's
when I just had to realize that there's
a level of spiritual Darkness at play
here that's the only thing I can explain
when this level of nihilism and that's
what you just described him a
comprehensive nihilism whether it's
people's craving greed whether it's
their their they've given themselves
another group has given themselves over
to malthusian ethics at a nihilistic
nietzschean level okay of depopulation
whether it's all of those things whether
it's stupidity whether it's complacency
pour all that stuff in a cauldron add a
little dash of Newt an eye of bats okay
and a cup of water and boil it together
and pour it out and and what you see is
systemic decline of a civilization and
that's what we're living through right
now how do we reinvigorate Spirit like
Jesus tried but they just killed him off
and made a religion out of them and
they're like worship him now and it's
like dude he was trying to wake people
up to God how do we any time I've seen
in the past people try they get co-opted
and Cults get made out of them and then
they just the war machine moves on the
Roman Empire started a church well
here's what here's what I would say
no one remembers almost any of the names
of the Roman War Machine
everybody still remembers Jesus name
we Mark time by the way we we Mark time
human civilizations Mark time by the
birth and death of Christ all right the
most the the most attended worship event
in the of the year in human civilization
for going on a second Epoch is the is
the is the marking of the resurrection
of Christ followed only by the marking
of the birth of Christ so I would argue
his legacy is very intact when it's
those of people like me who believe that
he is God that he was resurrected and
the CH the testimonies that we have of
the changes that have gone on in our
lives and then we have gone on and
helped other people and do things that
are beyond our normal capability so we
don't give ourselves over to the
nihilism that Tim talks about I would
argue his legacy is intact all the
people that put him to death they're all
in the ground all right nobody cares
about any of them but Christ is still
exalted and hailed and worshiped two
thousand years later so I think his
legacy is in really good shape thanks
for watching this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time